please welcome out Adrian vanallen hi
there so how are Natural History
collections shaping our future kind of a
strange question to ask but as an artist
and anthropologist in a designer I work
with the global genome initiative at the
Smithsonian National Museum of Natural
History in Washington DC and they have
decided that their project is to
cryopreserve all families of life in the
next six years so they're trying to take
genome quality tissue samples and put
them into liquid nitrogen for imagined
unknown future uses so if we're talking
about imagined futures this is a
beautiful place to start so as a
cultural anthropologist but also as a
photographer I worked with them to
understand what kinds of choices they
were making what they were deciding to
preserve what they were deciding to
discard and the ideas that were driving
how they decided to make those choices
so I photograph the operational
sequences of how specimens turn into
data in the back rooms of museums so
studying the scientific culture in the
back rooms of museums is a way to
understand how research comes into being
how the preservation of nature is being
shaped by ideas about what nature
actually is so my method for doing this
was not just a photograph the
collections but learn to make them
myself to get a hands-on craft
ethnography perspective on this so I
learned to stuff bird skins to pin
beetles to press plants but then also to
take molecular samples to extract DNA
and to take genome quality tissue
samples and assemble the genomic data so
both morphological and molecular
collections and how they actually are
changing and how they intersect in the
body of the specimen so thinking about
how to make specimens how nature is
being crafted in an age of genomics
really led me to look inside the body of
these
Simmons themselves to actually take
apart a bird so slitting it open
cleaning the skin stuffing it with
cotton sowing it closed this operation
is completely understandable to a
specimen preparator in 1850 at the
Smithsonian but at the current moment
we're also taking the bird guts out
taking a tissue sample and putting that
into the biorepository however that bird
guts the biohazard from the division of
birds then also migrates to the division
of parasites where they can extract a
tapeworm a valuable specimen for them so
biohazard in one division becomes
valuable field site in another so as
animals come apart in the back rooms of
museums they assume different kinds of
value and meaning as they move across
these borders and boundaries as they
shift between contexts they actually
change what they mean to different
people so understanding this required
digging in and understanding how the
network of specimens as they come apart
in the back rooms is not just between
divisions and departments it's also on a
global scale so a bird skin could be in
the division of birds a tissue sample
could be at a biorepository around the
world and the genome data could actually
be up in the cloud accessible to
scientists around the world so
collections collections are not just
objects are not just a dusty collection
to be ignored they're actually an
assemblage of people of places of
changing tools like genomics and of
ideas the ideas about what nature is how
it's shaping the future that we're all
going to have and our shared ecological
future is actually being built right now
so while a lot of attention has been
paid and deservedly so to climate change
to biodiversity loss that focus is on
the research itself instead I have
focused on the researchers and their
ideas that are shaping those collections
and how those collections and the data
they produce are going to shape our
collective future so future nature is
actually being crafted handcrafted in
intricate detail in the back rooms of
museums right now and it's actually
something we all need to
engage in to understand the multiple
futures that are being imagined and made
and remade and engage with how those
choices are being made and how we want
to build our future together thank you
very much
you